he carried your comments after this
short draw against yanipong nishi why
did you decide to play today the quick
game
well i mean it's always on the player
with the white pieces generally i mean
if the start to play with the black
pieces take some big risk then it can be
interesting but i mean i think the thing
is at the end of the day um jan
obviously is very well prepared and
i didn't really think it was worth it to
to risk a loss um and i just wanted to
be solid and um yeah yawn obviously he's
happy to draw because he's leading
determined by so many points so it's
what it is um i mean maybe a little
disappointing it wasn't more of a game
but i think if i had tried i think i
very easily could have gotten to a lot
of trouble and loss so yeah do you think
it was your last chance actually to
fight here in the tournament for the
first place or it was not really
no i mean i think the thing is if i look
at the wrist reward even if i win the
game i think it's very unlikely uh
because i don't have great pairings i
mean i have white against dude on around
13 but i have black and stinging around
14. so
i don't think it was
realistic i think the the opportunity
was was the game against timor i think
that was the game that if i don't lose
lose there would have been chances i
mean if i don't lose that i'm still on
plus one i have two whites i mean
they're i think i think i have decent
chances uh of course you never know if
results go the same way but i think that
was the
opportunity that was one game of black
that i
kind of needed something more than what
happened yeah how difficult it is
actually to satisfy your audience and at
the same time follow your goals in the
tournament
yeah i mean obviously people aren't
going to be thrilled by the draw today
but at the end of the day um
as i said it's it's more about risk
reward what what the possibilities are
and i think that
uh well while i assume magnus is going
to play maybe he won't and if he's not i
mean i at least want to have that shot
at second place um so yeah that's just
just how it goes and i also have to say
as i mentioned before i mean the fact
that i played this in a couple games
like right before this event in the rcc
and i mean i lost this horrible game to
photosav um it just yeah i i didn't
think it was worth uh doing something
stupid yeah what are you going to do
during this kind of three days like
today and tomorrow um i mean i've been
here quite a while i've gone by the
palace a few times i guess now with nato
out of town um it should be back to
normal um but i'll probably go walking
around madrid's been pretty nice overall
i know a lot of people they talk about
the north and the south we talk about
like basque country san sebastian bilbao
or barcelona down south um
but it's it's been very pleasant i've
enjoyed i've enjoyed my time here um and
uh i'll probably just go walking just
relax and uh you know start thinking
about what my plans are for after this
event yeah and the last question from
our followers of santa claus chess club
they were wondering what do you have in
your lucky bag
oh i just have like some fruit some
chocolate nothing nothing special just
just some dried fruit
fried fruits and some chocolate you know
the usual stuff oh yeah crazy and do you
believe that it helps you during the
game i mean i don't think it helps but
it's good to have some stuff in case i
have long games i've actually had a lot
of really long games throughout the
tournament so you just want to have
something to be safe